- Arguably, the most important
part of a business document
is its introduction.
It is so important to
from the very beginning,
capture the interest of your readers,
also of your viewers if
you're presenting something.
This is exactly what we are
going to talk about today
in this video,
My name is Heinrich, welcome
to my channel, Firm Learning.
This is the place where I want
to help you become successful
in the first years of your career.
Today, I want to introduce
you to a framework,
an introduction framework,
that is taught in almost
every onboarding program
of any of the large consulting firms,
like McKinsey, BCG, or Bain.
I trust this will be important,
because it's just so versatile.
You can use it for almost
every business document
that you use.
The first that I want you to understand
is that good business writing
is not something that either
comes or does not come to you.
Like many other things,
it's a skill that needs to be
practiced and can be learned.
And for sure, in consulting
onboarding programs
at the large strategy consulting firms,
this always played a big role.
And an important part of
that is the introduction,
because, compared to
people reading a book,
clearly no one will ever be as excited
to read your business document
as the person might be excited
just to read their favorite
book, their favorite novel,
that is just filled
with action, excitement,
or whatever other topic they
are really interested in.
So as a good business writer,
with your introduction,
you want to create at least a
little bit of this excitement,
of this interest of your
reader in your document.
So as most good books,
the introduction should have a beginning,
a middle part, and an ending.
And there is one framework
which is very commonly used
and taught in consulting firms,
and which I believe is at the core
of almost all good introductions,
and this framework is the framework
of situation-complication-solution.
So let's now go over
these three fundamental
components of introduction,
and let's start with the situation.
So the situation is the
start of introduction
where you briefly describe
how the situation currently looks like.
So here, you are looking
for a couple of sentences
where you know that other
people will agree to them,
so you know that the people
reading your document will say,
"Yes, this is exactly the situation
that we are currently facing.
This is what the status quo,
what this currently looks like."
So you don't want to go with
something controversial,
but rather something where you know
that you have the buy-in
of everyone reading this,
just to make sure that
this is captivating,
and you will have common
grounds with all your audience.
Of course, and this has then true
for the other parts as well,
how detailed this is going to be
will depend on the overall
context of your document.
So if your total
document, your total memo,
is only two or three pages long,
probably this whole introduction
will only be one or two paragraphs,
whereas if your document
is 50 pages, 100 pages,
or even longer,
then likely, this introductory part
can also be one or two
pages or so, or even longer.
What's important for these first sentences
of your situation part
is that what you write is captivating
so it leaves the reader being interested
in what you are saying
and wanting to understand further
how the situation will evolve,
what you will have to
say about the situation.
So this is this first
part of your introduction.
So let me make a couple of examples
for what sentences you could
write here for the situation.
Here, I'm looking at my
other screen to read them.
So for instance, you could
write something like,
"The profit margin of our company
has been steadily declining
over the last five years."
That seems interesting.
So what do we do about this, right?
This is then the next question,
how this will be, maybe,
hopefully of interest to your readers.
Or next, "The public health crisis
our world is currently facing
created a significant impact
on our everyday life."
So again, an uncontroversial statement
that somehow leaves me asking,
"Okay, what do we do?
How does this continue?"
Or next, "YouTube channels
have a great capacity
to teach educational material."
So I hope we all agree with that,
but once again, what does this mean?
What is the implication of that, right?
So this is exactly the effect
that you want to create.
Start with something uncontroversial,
and then build, based on that.
So before we now continue,
let me introduce you to the
sponsor of this week's video,
DataCamp.
DataCamp is an online learning platform,
where you can improve
your data analysis skills.
And you know that this is something
I talk about all the time.
This is really a crucial
part of your skill set
if you want to succeed
in any consulting role,
and, I trust, in many roles in industry,
and for sure, in banking, as well.
With DataCamp, there are no
previous data skills needed
to get started.
You can learn from things
as basic as Excel 101
to more advanced technical things,
like, for instance, database
manipulation in SQL.
So for sure, if the things that I show you
here in this video
are over your head,
you really have no idea
what this is all about,
there are some also very
introductory courses on Excel
in DataCamp, which I trust can help you.
They have over 300 courses
with interactive learning,
and you can also learn on the go
with a mobile app that they have.
Personally, I very much like
the Introduction to SQL course,
which already helped me several
times on my own projects
when I needed to interact with databases.
So give it a try, and I trust
that working with DataCamp
indeed can fast-track
your data analysis skills,
and these, for sure, are so
crucial in any consulting role,
but also many other related roles as well.
So if this piqued interest
and you would like to try out DataCamp,
then invest in yourself.
Check out DataCamp via the
link in the video description.
and you will get access
to the first chapter of every
single course, for free.
Let's continue with part
two of your introduction,
and this is the complication part.
So these should be, then, the sentences
that directly follow the situation part.
And here, you're now
introducing some elements
which make the whole
situation a bit more complex,
a bit more complicated.
Maybe there's an additional problem
that is part of the situation
that you are describing.
So something that maybe now
is indeed a little bit more controversial.
So here, maybe there are
some people in the room
or some people reading this
that would not necessarily agree,
or maybe this is just a
little bit more controversial,
but this is then fine for the second part.
One thing that's important to understand
is that the complication
does not necessarily need to be a problem.
It can also just, indeed,
be just an additional factor
that adds to the complexity,
an additional factor
that just makes the whole
situation more interesting,
more worthwhile of our attention.
Things like that can be
great complications as well.
Now, to make it a bit easier for you
to understand what a
strong complication is,
let me talk about this book,
"The Pyramid Principle".
This is a book that I
already recommended to you
in some of the prior videos,
and in the video today,
I'm also borrowing on a couple of concepts
that are explained in this book,
and indeed the
situation-complication-solution framework
is also a framework that is
picked up in here and explained.
And here there are a couple of examples
what great complications could be.
Let me just read a couple of
them for you, to make it clear.
So a good complication could
be, something went wrong.
So you introduced the situation,
and now you are adding an additional point
that shows how something went wrong.
Or another one could be,
something could go wrong.
So what would that be?
Like, what are you describing?
Something could go wrong
in the situation that
you are currently facing.
Something changed, or
something could change.
So maybe we all agree that currently,
the situation looks like this,
but maybe this is not how
it will look like forever,
or here's what you might
expect to find in it.
So what exactly is in the situation,
what is going on?
Or here's someone with a
different point of view.
Maybe we all agree
that this is how the situation
currently looks like,
but other people hold these other views.
This is how other people see it.
Or in this situation, we
have three alternatives.
So this is currently what we are facing,
and this is now what we could do about it.
So I hope you understand
the complication does not
necessarily need to be a problem,
but just something that
adds to the situation,
makes it a little bit more spicy,
more worthwhile of our attention.
Then the last part of the complication
should always be a question,
a question that builds on the complication
and is then usually the most
logical question to ask.
So for instance, if, then
you are introducing in the complication,
the point that someone else
might have a different view on something,
well, then, the question
is, so what is this view?
Or if we have now three
potential solutions
to address an issue,
what are these solutions,
what could we do?
Or if the situation is
changing, how is it changing?
So always asking this
logical, next question,
that also the reader
will ask him- or herself,
because this is, of course,
what captivates the interest,
what these people want to know.
And now it starts to become
a little bit like an interesting book,
where you just want to
know how it continues,
how this goes on.
This is exactly how you want to captivate
the interest of the people.
Now let's continue with
the solution aspect
of this introduction,
so the last aspect of it,
and of course, the solution should provide
a nice and concise answer to the question
that you posed in the
complication segment.
What's here also important to understand,
is that similar with the complication,
the solution does not
necessarily need to be
a solution to a specific problem,
just call it like that
just to make it a bit
more, like, actionable,
but it can also be understood
just as a key message,
a key insight that you want to share.
So based on the questions
that we just asked ourselves earlier,
you provide a good and clear answer,
the solution, the key message
that you want to share,
and which is now the starting point
for the top-down communication message
that you will have now to follow,
that's the starting point
to the main document
that you are now outlining.
What's important about
the solution section,
also to provide a proper introduction then
to the main part of the document,
is then, in the end, to also outline
the main structure of the document.
So talk to the reader about
what they can now expect
if they continue reading.
So how have you structured it?
How have you now detailed the solution
in the main part of your document?
What's important on this, though,
is also discussed in many
of my slide writing videos.
Once again, if you're
interested more in this content,
I will link this slide writing
playlist of my channel above.
It's important that you do
not talk about the structure,
but rather the ideas, the contents,
so avoid saying now, in
the solution in the end,
that now the document, for instance,
will also outline enablers of your idea,
but instead, in half a sentence,
write what the most important
enabler for your solution is.
So to make this now easier to understand,
let me just provide you
with a simple example
of how such a total
introduction could look like,
now based on a document
that is maybe rather short,
and not that long,
and this introduction goes as follows.
Let me just read it out to you.
"The profit margins of our company
have been steadily declining
over the last five years."
This is the situation as we've
already seen it also earlier.
Next, this is now the complication.
"In addition, new competitors
have entered our home market this year,
putting additional pressure
on our market share.
What can we do to address this issue?"
So here, now, you're
introducing an additional factor
that makes it even more challenging,
maybe it's a bit more controversial also,
but surely it provides, why act now.
It provides an answer to the question
why now something needs to happen,
why this whole issue
is really worthwhile of
our attention right now.
And indeed, now you
could continue in saying,
"This report outlines how a shift
from product selling to solution selling
could defend our market share
and increase our profitability.
We will highlight what processes
and capabilities we need
to make this happen,
and how the implementation
roadmap looks like."
So here now, in the solution
segment of the introduction,
you're first saying
what your hypothesis is
of how this could be addressed,
namely the shift from product
selling to solution selling,
and now you also provide a brief outline
of what is that we follow,
namely, what the key segments are,
but rather in the terms of ideas
in our structure elements,
namely, processes and capabilities
which you feel like are a
very important part of that,
but also the implementation roadmap,
and how this will look
like, how this will happen.
So situation-complication-solution.
It is just my humble experience
that if you set up your
introductions in this way,
you will, in most cases, succeed
in providing quite an effective
and also interest-capturing introduction
to your business documents.
I can just encourage you to try this out
in the next document that you write.
And of course, let me know
how this worked out for you.
What I can only tell you
is that this is just a framework
that is applied excessively in consulting.
What do you think about using
the situation-complication-solution
framework
for your introductions?
Does this makes sense?
Do you have other things that you know,
that you would love to share
with the Firm Learning community?
Please let me know in the comments.
And as always,
if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to this channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
I once again want to thank DataCamp
for sponsoring this video
and thereby contributing to
the firm learning community.
And of course, also big thanks
to all the members of Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday,
so see you soon next week.
Until then, all the best to all of you,
and bye-bye.